proxima centauri dieser rote zwerg stand
ist unser nächster stellare nachbar denn
er befindet sich nur etwa 4,2 lichtjahre
von der erde entfernt vor rund zwei
jahren konnten forschungsteams einen
erdähnlichen planeten aufspüren der
proxima centauri in seiner bilanz ohne
umkreis proxima centauri b gilt somit
bislang als sehr ehrt nächste
exoplaneten er ist möglicherweise nicht
der einzige begleiter von proxima
centauri existiert möglicherweise ein
zweiter planet und wenn ja wie können
wir uns vorstellen krieg science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierend ist
seins videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen bei dem neuen proxima
centauri c könnte es sich um eine super
eisige welt mit rund 6 erdmassen handeln
hat unser nächster nachbar der rote
zwerg stand proxima centauri neben dem
exoplaneten proxima centauri b
tatsächlich einen weiteren bislang
unentdeckten begleiter das legt
zumindest eine aktuelle analyse eines
internationalen astronomie teams nach
dazu der wissenschaftler mario damaso
wir freuen uns ihnen den ersten blick
auf das zu ermöglichen was wir für einen
neuen planeten kandidaten im auge zu
behalten
wir haben es trotzdem ac getauft die
fachleute hatten bei ihren beobachtungen
vor allem die leichte hin und her
bewegung des sterns im visier
denn dieses taumeln legt nahe dass er
unter dem graphit aktiven einfluss von
planeten steht die linien und kreisen
die forschenden konnten in ihren
modellen zeigen dass die stern bewegung
selbst dann eine periodische
unregelmäßigkeit aufweist wenn der
einfluss von flers also strahlen
ausbrüchen und dem bekannten planeten
proxima centauri berücksichtigt wird
durch anwendung der sogenannten
radialgeschwindigkeit methode kam das
astronomenteam zu der erkenntnis dass
ein gesteinsplanet den roten zwerg stein
umkreisen könnte diese methode eignet
sich sehr gut um planeten zu entdecken
dafür wird die radial geschwindigkeit
der sterne in bezug auf die erde
gemessen um die hypothetischen planeten
kreisen könnten in bestimmten zeitlichen
abständen werden dafür hoch aufgelöste
spektren des sterns aufgenommen denn
durch die zusammensetzung eines sterns
und seinen licht erzeugen prozessen
entstehen ganz
touristische spektren daraus können
fachleute dann sogenannte doppler
verschiebung herausrechnen wenn sich die
geschwindigkeit des sterns in bezug zur
erde ändert ja und das wiederum lässt
rückschlüsse auf die mögliche existenz
von planeten zu weiterhin sind in die
analysen auch messungen des harps
spektrografen das la silla
observatoriums eingeflossen so kam das
astronomenteam also auf den
hypothetischen planeten proxima centauri
zieht dieser wäre
den berechnungen zufolge möglicherweise
etwa sechs erdmassen schwer und somit
eine super erde
zudem ist der extrem kalt flüssiges
wasser ist hier wohl nicht zu erwarten
dazu der astrophysiker fabio del sordo
wir schätzen dass die
oberflächentemperatur von proxima
centauri nur etwa 40 kelvin beträgt
umgerechnet sind das minus 233 grad
celsius die analyse der vorstand zeigt
also ganz deutlich falls proxima
centauri tatsächlich existiert wäre
leben auf diesem planeten nicht möglich
und noch mehr konnte das forschungsteam
herausfinden die umlauf dauer des
gesteinsplaneten würde fünf erdenjahre
entsprechen und zwar in etwa demselben
abstand wie der mars die sonne umkreist
bei dem erst 2016 entdeckten planeten
proxima centauri b ist das anders er ist
mindestens 1,3 mal so massereich wie die
erde und vielleicht sogar warm genug
dass dort leben existieren kann doch
warum ist solch ein schwergewicht wie
proxima centauri c nach seiner
entstehung nicht ins innere des systems
gewandert möglicherweise weil unsere
derzeitigen vorstellungen über die
entwicklung von planeten einfach nicht
stimmen und diese dringend überarbeitet
werden müssen doch bevor die existenz
des hypothetischen proxima centauri c
bewiesen werden kann sind auf jeden fall
noch weitere daten und auswertungen
notwendig auch das verantwortliche
forschungsteam unterstreicht das noch
einmal dazu farbe der sordo der nachweis
ist sehr schwierig wir haben uns oft
selbst gefragt ob das ein echter planet
ist aber eins ist sicher selbst wenn
dieser planet nur ein luftschloss ist
sollten wir weiter daran arbeiten ein
festes fundament zu verschaffen
beispielsweise könnte die esa-sonde gaia
dabei helfen mehr details zu der taumel
bewegung von proxima centauri zu
bekommen zukünftigen teleskope könnten
den potenziellen planeten nach ansicht
der fachleute vielleicht sogar direkt
beobachten doch das mysteriöse
taumelndes stern proxima centauri
erlaubt auch noch andere
interpretationsmöglichkeiten
denn diese hin und her bewegung könnten
nicht nur durch ein schwergewicht wie
proxima centauri c hervorgerufen werden
sondern auch durch die existenz mehrerer
leichter begleiter dafür spricht auch
die theorie dass sich systeme von vielen
kleinen und felsigen planeten um
massearme sterne bilden auch
informationen die das radioteleskop alma
geliefert hatte sprachen bereits dafür
dass sich mehrere planeten in dem proxy
x system befinden neue studie zeigt
außerirdisches leben könnten ganz nah
sein
da geht es nämlich um proxima centauri b
der laut studie lebensfreundlich ist
hammer also anklicken anschauen und
neugier zone sehr cool as 1-kanal
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran